Sam the directors message in the press
kit for the citizen your film you
mentioned that it's a deeply personal
story it took you about three years to
finish writing why is the film such a
personal project you well you know as an
immigrant myself a movie about an
immigrant has to be a personal story and
living the circumstances that that
Ibrahim lived in the you know in the
story as far as you know coming here to
the US you know prior to 9/11 and living
here even though I came a little earlier
than ever him in the movie and just
experiencing you know what America is
all about
and Michael even an American the
American Dream and open all kind of
things I mean that that's really I mean
it's very personal to me because I think
the entire movie was built on that on
the American Dream theme which is you
know a lot of people thought after 9/11
this dream has banished or would never
exist anymore what I really felt that
you know the American Dream never dies
and the reason I say this because I feel
this country the u.s. is built it has
been built on Britain on a solid
structure and a solid foundation and
there's a constitution and a
constitution that if we always refer to
this country will be in a good shape you
know I I believe right now we're going
through circumstances that might make
the American dream little harder to
accomplish but that only means that we
have to work harder to earn it so yes it
is it is a personal story and it is not
my personal story the entire movie and
there's little pieces of you know belong
to me but the rest belong to two Ibrahim
in the movie I I hope my life is not as
dramatic as Ibrahim wife's in the movie
well the film was written wife
sure absolutely that the movie I mean
it's the story I came up with and and I
started writing that that's the script
and later I brought another writer
Jasmine Brown and he's a like co-writer
on the script and he give to work I mean
worked with me we work together on the
movie he did a great job bringing his
personality and you know elevating the
script and you know revising things and
you know making sure that you know it
belongs to people more and later at a
later stage we might produce a partner
Chris Wyatt and he's the one who
produced Napoleon Dynamite he's my
partner and he said that you know we
have to bring somebody who who lived the
9/11 who was there in New York and who
is really a New Yorker so we make this
script as authentic as possible and I
thought that was you know a great idea
and I absolutely I agreed with him on
this so we brought Sam Eunice and he's a
playwright and he's an award-winning
playwright and one of his plays you know
turned over to - it's a book and and he
left he was there in New York during
9/11 events and at the same time he his
roots go all the way to 11 on his dead I
think a mom or are Lebanese or maybe one
of them so he he cut the great mix for
us that that the good ingredients and
the great ingredients to it you you know
to help our project as far as his roots
as far as him being in you know New York
as far as you know him being you know
experiencing the 9/11 event so basically
it was yeah and efforts between you know
on my end and Jasmin and Sam and the
script took three years until we wrapped
her up and we were ready for production
in color
I see the email through my manager that
there is a director called Sam caddy who
wants to send you a script this is the
proper emailing and we send back years
and I receive the script and I love the
idea very much and then I called Sam
then we met in Cairo and then it clicked
and then we put it when you read of
Abraham's character what was your take
of this man who did you envision him as
he's a good guy he is the real image of
Arabs really you know I received this
script in 2010 and few months later we
made the greatest revolution in Egypt
and we made the Arab Spring and this is
the real image of Arabs and it's
important that we do a movie like this
to fix the image for the people the
American people because they are very
kind very smart very hardworking and
they are help there is a big difference
between the administration and the
people a big difference and we should
work always as artists for the people we
have to tell them this is how we are you
were manipulated by a wrong image
through the media we are not the 19 ones
who has done 9/11
fifteen or whatever we are 300 mini and
it's the right that we fix this and
parts are Ibrahim is is an enucleated
guy he is smart
his kind his head from his he achieves
what he achieves through a huge effort
is a very hardworking guy nothing is for
granted for him he's a good guy
you